[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause] [Music]
pretty shot of annapolis there a place i
know well some 28 million children ages
5 to 11 could start receiving the covet
vaccine as soon as next wednesday that's
because the fda is expected to grant
emergency youth authorization for
kid-sized doses of the pfizer vaccine by
tomorrow
and that would clear the way for the cdc
to make its recommendation next week
meaning kids could start getting shots
at pediatricians offices or schools very
soon maryland's republican governor
larry hogan says his state is ready to
roll out vaccines for children and he
joins us now good morning governor thank
you for being here we are clearly
entering new and quite emotional
territory when we're talking about
vaccines and kids right you've been very
big on recommending vaccines for people
what do you say to parents who are
feeling a little iffy about their
younger ones getting in well i can
understand the concerns because there's
been sort of confusing information a
conflicting information sometimes and so
some parents are concerned and we want
to do whatever we can to make sure that
they get the information they need and
talk with their physicians talk with the
professionals and but we think it's
important for them to move forward you
know our state is one of the most
vaccinated in the country we've done 98
of our seniors 80 percent of all
eligible marylanders and now we're
looking forward to being we're ready for
when we do get the approval to finally
move forward with the 5 to 11 year olds
so you would recommend it for parents i
absolutely would i mean it's definitely
keeping people safe we have the lowest
positivity rate in america declining
hospitalizations it's really keeping
people safe do you think it would only
be a recommendation or could the covert
vaccine soon enter the list of other
vaccines that we require of kids as they
enter public school
well i i think at this point it's going
to be a recommendation and that's what
they've done with every other rollout of
any phase of the vaccine program and i
don't think they're going to mandate the
five to 11 year olds don't think they
should mandate it but i think we should
encourage the parents to make those
decisions and to get their kids
vaccinated let's talk about the vaccine
overall sort of vaccine politics because
it's a little bit confusing for me right
so we have a vaccine that was launched
under president trump a republican
administration he got the vaccine you're
out there saying you got the vaccine
other republicans are as well and yet
we've got 64 million people who haven't
gotten it and it seems like it's been
politicized there's no question about
that what went wrong you know i think
there's been uh you know misinformation
and disinformation all over the place
and people believing things that just
aren't true i mean you hear all the time
but the vaccines are bad the vaccines
are killing people there's chips in the
vaccines it's craziness look the fact is
i'm a republican governor our state is
uh has vaccinated uh you know just about
everybody that needs to get one we're
going to finish out those last whatever
13 percent of the population we're going
to get our kids done it works uh you
know it the vaccines were designed to
prevent hospitalizations and deaths and
it works amazingly well who bears
responsibility for all that
misinformation you mentioned well i
think there are a lot of people
responsible there's no question that
president trump made some mistakes in uh
not taking it seriously i mean they did
a great job on operation warp speed
actually getting the vaccines developed
and out there uh but they did a terrible
job of the communications and uh you
know kind of telling people it wasn't
important when it was critically
important to save lives yeah so let's
talk about the politics of
infrastructure and i mean the actual
infrastructure roads bridges internet
the reason i want to talk about it is
because the estimates are that if
infrastructure passed it would create up
to a million jobs most of them for
people with high school or trade school
education and by the way it would pay 70
000 a year or more yeah we need that in
this country absolutely we do why can't
it get done you know it's really
frustrating i've been involved in this
from the beginning you know i i hosted a
pulled together a summit unprecedented
of democratic and republican governors
senators and congressmen back in april
we reached an agreement on this
bipartisan compromise 1.2 trillion we
got president biden on board it passed
overwhelmingly in the senate 69 votes
two and a half months ago and it's been
held hostage in the house by the
progress progressive democratic caucus
who's holding it up saying we're not
going to agree to the president biden's
compromise bill
uh unless we get the three and a half
trillion of other non-infrastructure
stuff
it's not a compromise if you say we'll
only do it uh if we get everything we
want that's not the way things work they
can come back and debate those other
things later but you know to be fair
it's not only the democrats who are
holding this up and infrastructure was
something that the uh trump
administration talked about for years
became kind of a running joke both
parties have failed for decades and
we're finally at the goal line about to
get it done for the american people and
we just need the congress to put aside
their differences and really get it done
because it's very important for the
country
so
you know i'm going to ask about the
white house
you know it certainly looks like you're
running for president i'm not sure why
it looks like that just because i'm
sitting here with you this morning here
you're on national television uh you're
in new york uh possibly to meet with
donors uh you uh have been traveling
around the country uh campaigning
raising your national profile uh fair to
say you're exploring it
i'm not sure that's fair to say that
it's not quite at that point look i i
have uh until january of 23 to be the
governor of maryland i'm going to be the
best governor i can be run through the
tape there's i'm very concerned about
the direction of the country about the
leadership in my party and so i'm out
there trying to do what i can to steer
the conversation to a more civil
political debate and talk about
solutions for the country but i haven't
made any decisions about what to do i
haven't made any decisions haven't ruled
it out i haven't ruled it out okay uh
you know
one of the the variables in whether you
run for president is whether president
trump returns to run in 2024. earlier
this year uh you first of all we should
say you voted for ronald reagan as a
kind of protest write-in vote in 2016 or
2020. um
earlier this year you were critical of
the prior president uh and his approval
ratings in the party had been dropping
but you know they bounced back up did
you miscalculate no i you know look it
doesn't uh my decision wouldn't be based
on what president trump does or doesn't
do uh first of all but yes there's no
question he dropped uh precipitously
after january 6th uh lost a lot of
support not only among americans in
general but in the republican primary
voter base that has seen a little bit of
an uptick because president biden's
failure on infrastructure the collapse
in afghanistan the pull out which was
bungled uh
his popularity has dropped into the 30s
which made people say maybe trump wasn't
so bad uh but we'll see a year is a
lifetime in politics we've it's only
been 10 months since the president's
been in president biden we have three
years until the presidential election so
i think it's far too early to speculate
these things go up and down bottom line
is we've got to bring the country
together and stop the divisive
dysfunction in washington and all the
angry finger pointing back and forth i
think a lot of people would agree with
you
popular republican governor from a blue
state interesting combination governor
larry hogan thank you very much thank
you